this evening in kabul as you all know
terrorists
attacked
that we've been talking about and
worried about
that the intelligence community
has assessed uh has undertaken
an attack by a group known as isis k
took the lives of american service
members
standing guard at the airport and
wounded several others seriously
he
also wounded a number of civilians and
civilians were killed as well
i've been engaged all day
in constant contact
with the military commanders here in
washington the pentagon
as well as in afghanistan and
doha
and
my commanders here in washington in the
field
have been on this with great detail and
you've had a chance to
speak to some
so far
the situation on the ground is still
evolving
and i'm constantly being updated
these american service members who gave
their lives
it's an overused word but it's totally
appropriate here we're heroes
heroes
who've been engaged in a dangerous
selfless mission
to save the lives of others
they're a part of an airlift an
evacuation effort unlike any scene in
history
with more than 100 000
american citizens
american partners
afghans who helped us
and others taken to safety
in the last 11 days
just the last 12 hours or so another 7
000 have gotten out
they were part of the bravest most
capable the most selfless military on
the face of the earth
and they're part of simply what i call
the backbone of america
they're the spine of america
the best the country has to offer
jill and i
our hearts ache
like i'm sure all of you do as well
for all those afghan families who lost
loved ones including small children
or been wounded in this vicious attack
and we're outraged as well as
heartbroken
being the father of a
army major who served a year in iraq and
before that
was in kosovo
as a u.s attorney for better part of six
months in the middle of a war
when he came home after a year
in a in iraq
was diagnosed like many many coming home
with an aggressive and lethal cancer of
the brain
but we lost
we have some sense like many of you do
what the families of these brave heroes
are feeling today
you get this feeling like you're being
sucked into a black hole
in the middle of your chest
there's no way out
my heart aches for you
but i know this
we have a continuing obligation
a sacred obligation to all of
you the families of those heroes
that obligation is not temporary it
lasts forever
the lies we lost today were lives
given in the service of liberty
the service of security
the service of others
in the service of america
like their fellow brothers and sisters
in arms who've died defending our vision
and our values
and the struggle against terrorism
of the fall on this day
they're part of a great noble company of
american heroes
to those who carried out this attack
as well as anyone who wishes america
harm know this
we will not forgive
we will not
forget we will hunt you down
and make you pay
i will defend our interest in our people
with every measure at my command
over the past few weeks
i know you're many you're probably tired
of hearing me say it
we've been made aware
by our intelligence community
that the isis k
an arch enemy
the taliban
people who were freed when both those
prisons
were opened
has been planning a complex set of
attacks on the united states personnel
and others
this is why from the outset
i've repeatedly said
this mission was extraordinarily
dangerous
and on why i've been so determined to
limit the duration of this mission
as general mckenzie said this is why our
mission
was designed this is the way it was
designed to operate
operating under severe stress and attack
we've known that from the beginning
as i've been in constant contact with
our senior military leaders and i mean
constant
around the clock
and our commanders on the ground
throughout the day
they made it clear that we can and we
must complete this mission and we will
and that's what i've ordered them to do
we will not be deterred by terrorists
we will not let them stop our mission we
will continue the evacuation
i've also ordered my commander to
develop operational plans to strike isis
k assets leadership and facilities
we will respond with force and precision
at our time at the place we choose in a
moment of our choosing
here's what you need to know
these isis terrorists will not win
we will rescue the americans
we will get our afghan allies
and our mission will go on
america will not be intimidated
and i have the utmost confidence in our
brave service members who continue to
execute this mission with courage and
honor to save lives and get americans
our partners our afghan allies out of
afghanistan
every day when i talk to our commanders
i ask them what they need what more do
they need if anything to get the job
done
as they will tell you i granted every
request
i reiterated them today on three
occasions
that they should take the maximum steps
necessary to protect our forces on the
ground on kabul and i also want to thank
the secretary of defense and the
military leadership of the pentagon and
all the commanders in the field
there has been complete unanimity
from every commander on the objectives
of this mission
and the best way to achieve those
objectives
those who have served through the ages
have drawn inspiration from the book of
isaiah
when the lord says whom shall i send
who shall go for us
the american military has been answering
for a long time here i am lord send me
here i am send me
each one of these women and men of our
armed forces are the heirs of that
tradition of sacrifice of volunteering
to go into harm's way to risk everything
not for glory not for profit but to
defend what we love and the people we
love
and i ask that you join me now
in a moment of silence
for all those
in uniform
and out
beautiful military and civilian
who've given the last full measure of
devotion
thank you
may god bless you all my god protect us
troops and all those standing watch for
america
we have so much
to do
it's within our capacity to do it
we just have to remain steadfast
steadfast
we will complete our mission
and we will continue
after our troops are withdrawn
to find means by which we can find
any american
who wishes to get out of afghanistan
we will find them and we will get them
out